recall that by default the browser
assumes that CSS is blocking hence the
first link tag will block rendering the
screen query will evaluate to true since
we are rendering the content on the
screen and it will also block rendering
the third declaration depends on the
orientation of the device in this
particular case because the handset is
in portrait orientation it won't be a
render blocking resource finally the
last declaration is only applied when
the page is being printed hence it is
not render blocking when the page is
first being loaded in the browser nice
so only two of the four render blocking
I can feel the pages getting faster
already